- crushed it
to long for some people I get it it's
not a YouTube thing
that's a make it in your cheek play
mother [ __ ]
[Music]
how many of you guys remember the scene
that happened right here what episode
was that number that recall
[Music]
but says for arriving live thank you how
are you good to see you nice to meet you
stop being full of [ __ ] goodbye example
to better
all internal right yes all internal from
a global perspective no no if you you're
happy with it so Weston Reeves just
tweeted uh how can I get a signed book
without buying one off of ebay I just
replied let me make sure I get the exact
reply because I'm just replied I know
what I wrote um you just got one Garrett
green who works with me and works with
Tyler is now gonna get one I'm gonna
come in the office we'll film it I'm
gonna sign it we're gonna send it and
I'm gonna post this video so every one
of you understand that scaling the
unscalable on going deep and living the
Thank You economy my secret best book
matters because it just does just doing
the right thing works it works in a way
that's hidden I don't know what the ROI
of less than means to me for the rest of
my life I don't know if this $44
execution is gonna return me money I
know that putting that into the
ecosystem is gonna bring value well
Weston tell that story four or five
times
probably heck I do it all the time but
now I made this piece of content that
may inspires but doing the right thing
is the right thing these are customers
these are people that are advocates
these are people that give a crap about
what you or your business do and we do
not treat them with the respect and the
gratitude and the empathy that they
deserve and thus our actions and
marketing don't reflect that and we
leave enormous amounts of long-term
brand-building value on the table in
exchange for short term sales tactics
[Music]
by the way great job Garrett 19 seconds
in boom jumped in ready and Weston right
back now you're the man Gary I
appreciate you and four or five people
already asking for another book to put
that whole little part at the end when
it as a yeah not in it yeah
after we ended you know the beep you
know
[Music]
we're the halfway point about three
years ahead
oh you know what I'll jump in there I
don't think I'm three years ahead I just
think I'm today you know three years I
genuinely believe that by the way and I
think it's because of reporting or the
politics within an organization I think
I bring whatwhat if I look at this last
five years that I've run my agency and
what what we the work we've done with
the biggest brands in the world is it's
just an entrepreneurial mindset you know
I think you need to make you need to
walk in with naive eyes to everything so
my big theory is I try to put myself out
of business every day bless you the
things that I'm passionate about
Facebook influencers Instagram for the
right brand snapchat I could care less
if they go out of business tomorrow
right I have no emotional ties to
anything I don't see any vested interest
in a long term for what works for me
three years ago to work for me now the
process of driving down creative costs
but not giving up quality big's by the
way quality is subjective you know but
it's perception when you pay for
something it's what you then you deem
it's value you don't value the video I
want to make for you for 37,000 the same
as you're above the line creative agency
charges you were 540 even if it was the
same exact thing that's how humans roll
what's interesting is there's an
appetite to not be romantic and that is
a mindset that is extremely attractive
and much needed you can't be tied to
anything right now it's just moving too
fast yes
see ya thank you
[Applause]
you know I think that obviously I'm out
and about in a in a very significant way
and so we'll bring awareness to it in
general outside of even client you know
current clients for Vayner which will be
a gateway to this opportunity also I
have a lot of people you know through my
own vlogging and things of that nature
that follow me filmmakers and things of
that nature on YouTube and other
platforms that will probably see this
association and have more you know maybe
I mean they should already know Vimeo
given the quality but I think it's a
brand play and a execution play so
obviously you know I think one of the
interesting dynamics of wow I saw this
is I'm a big believer that you have to
always reverse engineer what you're
doing for your client and so as you can
imagine in this jb if if this structure
executes the video work instead of my
own production in-house capabilities i'm
sharing the revenue in essence I'm
taking the dollars out of my own pocket
however I always want to give my clients
the best and brightest options in every
scenario so I think the support comes
from awareness branding you know being
out there speaking to it and then
obviously being a very extremely strong
sales engine to the opportunity and more
importantly helping a lot of these
incredible filmmakers understand the
nuances if they haven't worked in the
past with brands of the creative
freedoms and some of maybe the
limitations and so being a hand-holding
process to the interpretation I think
could be to make it go faster smoother
and more successful I think the thing
I've learned in building an agency in
the world where I used to interact with
them is having that context brings a lot
of value
3:01 p.m. big shout-out to sweet 301 and
Mount Ida kala
1994 you know how we did it Oh God
ya know I think there's a lot going on
miss we warden Gary I believe it
hey guys my flight
I think so you didn't get it so that's
how it is we don't need to do a [ __ ]
fancy let's just do it the way it
actually is and I don't know why we are
so over complicating it I know why I am
I'm not so sold why I with some
combination of you guys haven't figured
this out for me as well on that one
issues your backbone other than Gary's
have been into European why [ __ ] you
made that decision I know there's a
million people that work in New York
that do that well by the way that's
exactly the point here's the best part
I don't want to make anybody do anything
I do not want to meet Sally and you tell
me to convince her that the right path
for her is to become a unicorn I'm done
with unicorns I only want one unicorn
the guy that plays there that's a bit
boom in the slot go do your thing cuz
then we can go fast then we know exactly
what their titles are there's no
confusion now we layer the complications
everybody needs to get as far as they
can if you get to 100% alignment you
send me something that you say this is
100 percent of alignment I don't even
open the PDF I say a prove that we all
move fast that means to me the framework
that this company works on that is de
magic but we're spending way too much
time debating with you guys when I'm
gonna make the ultimate call anyway
right like I I'm the bottleneck in it
anyway
I'm gonna sign off somewhere so what's
really smart is us all succumbing to
that reality first one's better for you
it's better for me we don't waste time
we enjoy our interactions on moving the
company because we're just we just know
we're gonna do everything that we get to
agree on and then the parts we're not
we're just going to lie night on them
we'll probably spend a little more
because we have ambitions as being
senior people and trying to get to that
but I'm not there's gonna always be
those things and that's how we'll win
walk with us guys leave your kit laptops
here
unless you need it which you can bring
them to write and maybe write notes
I guess I'm just not a hurry and I got
it right I got it
penny more No Oh fantastic crushed yes
hey Katie yeah no there you go
what about um this is ridiculous what
it's right to CES I'm going to draw the
line you're speaking in New Orleans the
morning you're flying to CES lingo
privates looking like it might be 22 K
I'm looking for a cheaper one
you can go direct and get there sooner
but not first class or you can connect
and Houston or Dallas first class yeah
and what time I'll get there on time if
I connect I'm even to that evening you
can land it like 750 connect first class
it's like 7 or 8 o'clock local Vegas
time like the ability in the quality
level of the sea layer like I get credit
for things that I'm oblivious to you
know what I mean like just like that's a
good example like yeah like people like
think that I'm too cool hello I don't
feed her follow her oh my god you know
like the 11 by the way this is a story
my life you know that the only reason I
actually got girls to like me in high
school was that I was so into baseball
cards that when they started liking me a
little bit more my kind of my junior
senior year then I was a scared of them
still because I was maturing slowly and
be all I want to do was build businesses
that because I wasn't reacting to them
like me it made them like me more and
that's basically what's happening in
business like people think that I'm
doing something cuz I'm too cool or I
think it's like but it's in I'm just
sorry I'm just um that's the whole part
of it it is by accident it's always been
my accident cuz if you do it on purpose
the other person can taste it
but they just they just their
acquainting it a little different
they just think I might be too busy or I
have all these up news it's actually
just um just I don't know I didn't
follow I did not follow because well
actually maybe than an instrument
because I am Sofa maybe that actually is
true now that I think about it it's just
the most genuine [ __ ] yeah yes no more
Dona London
[Music]